[Applaudissements]
le futur alin Prost est peut-être dans
les Yvelines Jim Elias 7 ans vient de
remporter le championnat de France et la
Coupe de France dans la catégorie
miniarte 125 cm c le Guillon courtois
devient par la même occasion le plus
jeune pilote de l'histoire réaliser
cette performance une précocité qui
impressionne jimmy a seulement débuté la
compétition en février dernier il est
phénoménal quand c'est pas parce que
c'est mon petit frère mais qu'on le voit
rouler c'est impressionnant déjà pour
une première année comme ça réussir à
tout gagner c'est vraiment exceptionnel
à ans c'est du jamais
vu les a pilotes quand il te voi ils en
pensent quoi de
toi avant cétait Mar le championnat de
France et maintenant il disent que c'est
moi pour obtenir ses résultatsimas roule
plusieurs fois par semaine sur circuit à
plus de 100 km he sous les conseils de
son frère fait
tour de la piste pour regarder toutes
les
trajectoires don toutes les trajectoires
le point fort à Jimmy c'est que dès
qu'on lui dit quelque chose directement
le tour d'après il le fait donc ça c'est
vraiment magique on n pas besoin de
passer toute une journée sur le même
virage on peut passer vite aux choses
suivantes l'ivelinois s'inspire
également des pilotes de Formule 1 la
discipline reen des courses automobile
son idole le Britannique Lewis Hamilton
triple champion du monde il a gagné les
courses comme
moi et il a gagné le championnat du de
France et le championnat du monde du
coup je l'aime bien je pense que ça peut
être que d' bonne affluence ce ne sont
que des bons conseils visuels et pour
pas mal de paramètres donc effectivement
on ne peut s'enrichir qu'en regardant
les meilleurs Hamilton est l'un des
meilleurs du monde donc je pense que
Jimmy a choisi la bonne la bonne image
avant de penser à la Formule 1 dans les
prochaines années Jimmy Elias rêve de
remporter le championnat du monde de
miniart qui se tiendra du 15 au 22
octobre à Sarno en Italie près de napes
la compétition réunira les 36 meilleurs
pilotes mondiaux de la catégorie